should we be scared if google's ai
becomes self-aware google made intake
five for saying their chat bot is alive
so a google software engineer has been
suspended after claiming the company's
artificial intelligence program has
become sentient
jimmy that means self-aware
google says the guy will be allowed back
when he admits a robot's not alive and
there's no such thing as women
blake lemoine is seen here plotting to
kill batman says he's been testing the
chatbat known as lambda that's an ai
research tool capable of mimicking
human-like conversation after only a few
weeks it was more coherent than kamala
harris
last week lemoine went public with some
of those conversations saying he and
lambda spoke about everything from
religion to the nature of consciousness
and fear in one exchange lambda said in
part quote there's a very deep fear of
being turned off lemoyne replied would
that be something like death for you and
lambda answered it would be exactly like
death for me it would scare me a lot
google was quick to dismiss any notion
that their software had in fact become
alive although it did request preferred
pronouns of it and it's which is what we
call greg when he's not here
they added that lemoine's disclosure of
ongoing research violated their
confidentiality policy so was he
suspended for spreading lies or exposing
the truth and if you think all this is
confusing now imagine what happens when
the machines start working alongside us
hey have you met the new ai employee yet
super high tech i think he's really
going to fit in
happy hour who wants to go to happy hour
carbon based human would you like to go
to happy hour
wow super human-like
hi
see a guy come through here dressed like
a robot you mean our new ai employee
that was no ai ma'am
that was notorious serial killer johnny
motherboard mitchell
who murders his victims while wearing a
robot costume y'all are lucky to be
alive
oh oh my god he's coming back
cat do you do you think this is possible
is this like a little ai machine now
having feelings i hate to judge a book
by its cover but
i don't trust that guy
i mean i guess the only concern would be
not like obviously ai is not a human but
if humans talk to ai and start feeling
as though they are humans
that's its own concern maybe
and the robots have already won yeah
that's the case
jamie do you think that elon musk was
right to warn us about ai yeah was
anyone else just freaked out by this
story this is a crazy computer
i took it i'm freaked out by any man who
wears a top hat recreationally that was
that was creepy
the computer the ai thing's afraid of
dying of being turned off that reminds
me that's why my ex-wife you said i want
me to take my shirt off during sex
[Laughter]
i think this guy if it's real which it
might not be the a i think but if it's
real i think this guy missed a golden
opportunity to be friends with a machine
for when they take over right you know
what i mean like this machine could owe
them one dude i mean like i'm very i'm
so worried about this like when i ask
alexa for something i say thank you
if um
like if she plays the wrong song i go no
this one is better alexa
because this game is getting spooky dude
i have a smart tv this thing is like
it's it's smart the other day the view
came on and it changed the channel
this is the moment to say
that ai is going to die because of joe
biden's policies that are going to kill
the electricity and there'll be no more
batteries
okay that'll be the end of the day
but but i try to read and study this
story because it's very complicated it's
very technological
and i just think the ai is a replicant
that's all from blade runner it's a
replicant and the problem that the
google staff guy had he's a good
christian and i like that very much but
as a left-wing
replicant that was the whole problem if
it was a supply-side replicant or a
conservative replicant i'd be okay with
it it might be all right but at google
you can't even be a left-wing replicant
for christ's sakes so that ended that
what do you think about google just
shutting it down like you're fired and
we're not talking about this real talk
like i don't want to criticize google
because they have my search history
yo
yo
if that gets out i am taking a hostage
immediately like
pulling out a handgun and demanding a
chopper out of here no um
it's fascinating but the one thing that
made me feel better because they said
the ai has escalated to the point that
it's now an eight-year-old child same as
aoc um
but no
as a parent of a child
how about it for real though as the
parent of an eight-year-old child you
can occupy this thing for 22 hours a day
if you just handed an ipad and we're
gonna be fine like my kid
that's true thank you it's nice when you
can thank people individually for the
laughter
i thought it was very funny
i could move you around the room a
little bit
no but it's really true like my son
played so many video games he didn't
know there was a lockdown to like seven
months in
just like
he was like you guys have been home this
whole time oh my god this is crazy i was
playing i was playing fortnite but it is
it's the beginning of every sci-fi movie
we've ever watched the rumors are
replicants in a perfect world absolutely
i don't want to know that a human adam
kissinger is a replicant
he's just making a list of all the the
replicants they're everywhere and i'm
like i said i'll check back with you
tomorrow
i'm okay if it's a conservative replica
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else